[Música]
vamos directo a Brasil una de las
noticias del país este 10 de febrero es
que el supremo tribunal Federal remitió
el primer proceso contra el expresidente
Jair bolsonaro que ahora pasa a la
justicia ordinaria y como ya no ocupa
ningún cargo público bolsonaro perdió el
fuero especial que hacía que el supremo
fuera el único organismo que podía
investigarlo ahora la máxima autoridad
judicial remitió al tribunal Federal del
distrito de Brasilia siete solicitudes
de investigación contra el expresidente
conectamos entonces con nuestra
corresponsal Valeria sacone quien está
en Río de Janeiro Valeria buenas noches
y cuéntenos cuáles son esos casos que
pasaron a la fiscalía y al tribunal para
que investiguen a bolsonaro
si son siete las peticiones de
investigación contra el expresidente
Jair bolsonaro que la Corte Suprema ha
enviado a un tribunal de primera
instancia en el Distrito Federal donde
se encuentra Brasilia 5 están
relacionadas con ataques del presidente
contra la propia Corte Suprema y sus
miembros durante la celebración de la
independencia de Brasil el 7 de
septiembre de 2021 en estas
manifestaciones
bolsonaro atacó al juez Alexander
demorais al que considera un enemigo
personal y llegó a decir que no acataría
ninguna decisión Del supremo una postura
radical que le llevó a dar marcha atrás
unos días después cuando se dio cuenta
de las consecuencias legales que podría
tener sus palabras además un grupo de
diputados le acusa de racismo por decir
en un discurso comparar los habitantes
de una comunidad afrodescendiente
tradicional a animales cuando dijo
negros habría que pesarlos con arrobas
que es la unidad de medida usada para
pesar a los animales y además es
investigado por participar en una
motosiata un paseo de motocicleta en
Orlando en los Estados Unidos en el que
se encontró con un bloguero radical que
está huido de la justicia y contra el
cual está expedido una orden de
extradición además en las próximas
semanas podrían ser enviadas a otras
peticiones de investigación contra
bolsonaro por su supuesta incitación de
los actos antidemocráticos del 8 de
enero y por supuesto genocidio del
pueblo yanomami en la amazonía brasileña
Valeria y siendo así como queda la
situación legal del expresidente
bolsonaro puede ser extraditado desde
Estados Unidos donde está desde el año
pasado
la gran pregunta ahora puede ser
extraditado él reside en la ciudad de
Orlando en los Estados Unidos desde el
30 de diciembre donde se fue antes de la
investidura del actual presidente Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva llegó con un
visado de presidente y con la inmunidad
parlamentaria pero este visado expirado
las noticias que llegan es que estaría
tramitando un visado de turista por
primera vez en sus más de 30 años de
carrera parlamentaria como presidente no
tiene inmunidad y precisamente por esta
razón puede ser investigado por un
tribunal normal de primera instancia
habrá que ver por lo tanto si después de
la petición del supremo el tribunal
correspondiente abrirá la investigación
y sobre todo si pedirá una posible
extraditación es lo que ha dicho el
presidente Lula desde los Estados Unidos
donde visita Joe biden todo está en las
manos de los tribunales